let's try to move on to something that's
not completely
well it's still kind of enraging but in
a fun way
we haven't checked in on a while the
russian twins
that's a way better name that's a way
better name
uh crisscross applesauce and cte boy
the fighter and the kid somebody sent
this to me out and and
why don't we just play it what do you
say for those people who don't know
brett's brendan's shop
he's got to stop sitting indian style in
that chair man he looks like a freaking
child
yeah i hate it so uh let's let's check
in on this on this
great show that's just breaking it's
just if somebody sat like that
in your studio wouldn't you be like hey
get your [ __ ] shoes off my chair
here we go
he's getting older isn't it what is he
saying that's burrado
yeah he's got to be 60 something right
how old is he
he looks pretty good yeah that's his fam
there
i don't think so it's his daughter
59 only seven years older than you'd be
okay well that'll be me that will be you
it's gonna be fun though dude it made
fun when you look like that
yeah you're gonna make fun of me yeah
every day
why would you do that why is it okay to
make fun of somebody
for dying or slowly i don't know is it
fun though the closer you get to death
the more ruthless your friends are we're
all getting older though
yeah i don't know i don't i can't i've
seen about this on the way here
because it's uh shout out to andrew
schultz it's his birthday on
friday i think or thursday and he's 37
i don't know if i'm 36 or 37.
gun to the head hey dude 36 couldn't
tell you
unless you're like unless you're like a
foundling
i don't i mean he was raised by wolves
did they find him on the [ __ ] steps
of a firehouse yeah i don't understand
was he like danny devito and batman
returns it's all coming back
that's some i don't know
what are you talking what are you
talking i don't know how old i am shut
up
i don't know i'll give me your driver's
license and i'll tell you march 18
1983. so mike how old would that make
him
march 18th 1983 36. okay but i just want
to make sure that we're on the scene i'm
36 i'm may 13th i know 1983
36 36 okay how do you think he thinks he
is 42.
do the math i will not be able to do it
who's gonna
neither of you get a math you're 37. cat
37 i'll be 38 in march
he's 30 he thinks he's 30. 38. he just
said he didn't know if he was 36 or 37
and he was 38. he thinks he's 37 is what
he said
he was born in 1983 and he thinks he's
37.
not great isn't that crazy i've known
you since you were 29 i think
how long when how long ago was that uh
it was a long time ago
yeah how do you not know simple math
like that
this isn't like the pythagorean theorem
you know this is just do simple math
wow i know dude wow time for f
flies 37 i guess woohoo
what i don't know how i enjoy it morning
cause you're turning 38
i gotta ask something because i mean you
and i have been doing this show for a
while right and their shows an hour and
15 minutes long
have we ever had like this kind of
downtime
like and by downtime i mean just
nothing's really going on
they're not really talking they're not
joking yeah you know what it is
i've said this before waiting for the
next person to talk i've said this
before it actually
feels like uh
it feels like like you and a friend that
you haven't seen in like
you know 15 years got together and it's
like you know all that
nervous chatter that you have while
you're catching up
that's what it feels like one guy went
off to be married and one guy went to
prison
another catching up after 15 years and
they have nothing in common that's what
it feels like
and i don't really i don't watch their
show you know we obviously have clips
that are sent to us and
and stuff that's worth playing that
we've played on this show so is every
show like this
is that is every show like this damn
near 40 now
well i'm still two years away i'm just
saying that's how old are you two
42. there you go that's why you feel
that's why you celebrate that
cat what are you 24. sky they need that
many people to produce produce this show
duh cat's 24 years old god dawg god dawg
for men it's easy after you know it's
still coming your own
i believe it hundred percent things that
brian callan tells himself is amazing
you know for men it's easy you're still
coming to your own like you know i'm i
just divorced my wife
he rationalizes every shitty aspect of
his life that's what he's doing he's
rational
dude studio apartments are dope in the
city you know what i mean like you get
to like bro i could go get a slice of
pizza at like three in the morning if i
want
it's pretty cool it's it you're right
he's just like oh no man it's cool like
for one like
i could eat whatever i want now you know
what i mean ah
i got more room in my bed at bachelor
arms i sleep at a race car bed
i sleep in a big bed with my wife all
these [ __ ] little like
yeah man it's cool like i don't get to i
can sleep on in if i want some days it's
like so cool how like
men could still be coming into their own
at 52. no they can't the lies he tells
himself
are hilarious believe what well for men
as you get older is cynicism well i
thought it was interesting that
you know everybody from stallone to
anybody no matter how successful you are
you go through a period of time when you
feel like it's over and you're
irrelevant
sly told the whole most hilarious
entertainment not being able to get
a movie man he couldn't get the rocky
whatever it was made and
yeah and he [ __ ] was like sitting at
the bar
and he's like well it's over i had my
run it's over
i mean but dude but still it's a 90
movie it doesn't matter you still like i
did i had my run it's a form of death is
that how you felt after bad tv mr callum
is that is that how you felt after mad
tv was canceled
cabana boy and then uh his friend came
up with us how are you doing he's i'm
not doing good
not good because he wanted to make that
yeah and then then this this this this
producer said i read that script and
made my wife cry
so anything like that i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm doing the movie
but like you know you always think that
it's the last time you i've never been
an actor
or any other director that didn't feel
like this was their last gig
that it doesn't i'm done oh my god can't
[ __ ] shop i just noticed his
shoes i just noticed his
everything about him is just terrible
it's just terrible
you know everybody ever i think being
insecure
insecure is is is probably crucial
i don't know do you know anyone who's
not yeah i don't know it do you know
anyone who's
not no i don't name that one we should
talk about this only because you and i
are around successful people and there
are a lot of people who are younger
listening
when i was when i was your age when i
when when i was when i was in my 20s
i thought people who were up there were
secure like i thought that they had it
all and they had arrived i don't have
the same price there's no such thing
no right like part of what drives you is
the fact that you always feel like
you're
um less than well certainly no brian a
lot of people
don't feel that way a lot of people
lasted longer on mad tv a lot of people
have podcasts with more views a lot of
people
have a netflix special yeah
just say brian not everybody is
a uh insecure divorced uh 52 year old
man who still gets into bar fights
that's not everybody you don't speak for
everyone well did you hear his tape
can i borrow a feeling it's pretty good
that's not him though
what's the difference for me
i don't know where i'd be if i didn't
hate myself a little bit don't worry i
hate you too
don't worry brian plenty of people hate
you you don't have to hate yourself man
a lot of people are picking up that
burden
for you you got it you don't need to
carry that so it's okay if you don't
like yourself what matters is just take
the actions
and like divorce your wife and leave
your children yeah exactly
get into fist fights at 50 years old
that's that sounds like great life
choices maybe you're maybe you don't
like yourself brian because you're not
likable
yeah how about that how about you
realizing what everybody else has
realized about you
[ __ ] you got some self-awareness all
of a sudden keep reaching
you're never going to be self-perfected
but at least you'll get close guys got
guys in shape guys got a [ __ ] he's
got some forearms
what is it with them is it do they check
out like dudes and
and see how hot they are yeah they do
that a lot you know who they are
it's like two max from what's always
honey yeah exactly man i bet
dude a bit when he cuts the carbs out
and cuts water weight he probably looks
so [ __ ] shredded it's such a weird
color is that what they do they just
talk about how good people look
that's what it reminds me of was the uh
remember the the predator episode of
it's always sunny
yeah when they were gonna watch predator
and they were fighting over i don't want
to sit here and talk to you about carbo
loading and then
look at he's doing uh arnold's pretty
jacked too though
for his age never stopped he's never
stopped working out he looks great
arnold arnold's got a like do they go
into this like when we do our show
right we we go in with like a bunch of
prep and we're like hey we're going to
talk about this we're going to talk
about that
we're going to hit on this we're going
to hit on that what do they do with
their show they just kind of just sit
there and
hope something comes up yeah we'll just
riff it that's what all these comics do
none of them well no i'll give it to you
some people some comics actually
but a lot of them don't a lot of them
like you see these shows dude they've
seen them countless shows where they
just come in and go
he's gonna flip on the mics man we're
just gonna just gonna pee ourselves
max we're so funny dude i'm just
skipping ahead here because
remember this clip started at 15 minutes
so they've been talking about dudes for
three okay i'm gonna keep going
if you keep skipping it look look i'm
not even
and maybe they're done no now they're
looking at instagram models
now john travolta now
what is this show about they're just
hanging out man
i guess man i i i don't i don't
understand look obviously they have a
lot of people to watch them and i'm sure
they
they have their little fan base i
personally don't get it but
whatever good on you guys i hope you
guys crush plenty of puss